[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
oh
[Music]
ah
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
do
ah
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody happy tuesday we did it
it's here
the halo update finally finished on
steam thank you everybody who's been
hanging out in the chat he's been very
patient
uh we've stuck through this together and
now we can finally see what the heck is
up with this halo update
uh hi my name is john luke i'm a senior
video producer for gamespot
and i'll be hanging out with you guys
for the next
hour uh just uh i was gonna go
i was hoping to go for two hours but
obviously spent a whole hour here
waiting for this
dang update to
install so here we go
but we're going to go for the next hour
we're going to check out this update
we'll we'll look at uh the store we'll
look at the new maps hopefully
new modes i know they brought king of
the hill back they got that that new
mode called oh what is it i have it up
here um
[Music]
last spartan standing which is a new
take on gun game apparently so that'll
be interesting
all right you guys let me know the
volume is by the way if you need to up
the game volume or lower or whatever the
case might be
lowered a little bit on
okay
all right let's see here
lone wolves battle pass let's just check
that out
or not right afterwards like
doo doo doo
no cam today from bob jones on the
twitch no cam today i'm in the studio
and uh so we have cameras in the studio
but i set it up and the cameras were not
set up great so i uh
i turned that off because it was just
gonna look horrible so just voice today
uh okay let's see here can i
interesting that's not loading so i
guess i might not be able to check out
the battle pass yet
turn up mic volume okay i can try and do
that a little bit or i can try
readjusting it it's kind of at an
awkward angle for me hold on
here we go that might that might be
better
okay show me this battle pass watch
cinematic yeah let's do that
let's see what the cinematics all about
i have to load this
all right it's fine
more loading i love it
i've been staring at loading screens for
the last hour
ah
maybe this was a mistake
maybe i shouldn't have done this
it's too late now ready over fifty
percent
there we go i'm gonna lower my mic for
this
on me
[Music]
they aren't hostiles
they're wolves
back from the hunt
[Music]
[Music]
this neurolink is corrupted man i'll
have to pull the chip no
do that he dies
and we lose everything he risked his
life for
we were on a recon up
investigating banished activity at the
old unsc fleet depot on gamba
the one the covenant destroyed in 42.
the banners brought it back online
added their own ship-breaking gear
we spent two days watching them cut
apart one of our cruisers
then dean saw one of his opportunities
to improvise
yeah that sounds like something he would
say
what a good link okay show me
excellent
what exactly did spartan din put inside
his head a banished a.i
the first i've ever seen
that anyone has ever seen who dares to
change the mighty aratus
i will crush your bodies at feast
how did you find him
it found us
dean's opportunity was a gap in their
security protocols
we went in and i attacked
weaklings cowards you will beg for mercy
before the end we fought our way out of
their shipyard hijacked that phantom
but the ai followed
tried to offline the phantom's engines
locked down its flight controls
so din gave it a more
attractive target
one more thing
he made me promise to show you this
no matter what
it's guarding an archive
the entire banished operation on camber
whatever they were trying to learn it's
in here
and maybe a whole lot more
he's stable
barely
we got to get that thing out of him how
carefully
and then get it to tell us everything it
knows
[Music]
all right there we go then that was uh
it's fun seeing your own character in it
even though it's
i had the winter skin outfit i looked so
out of place
just me my cat ears you know how it be
uh anyway let's take a look at this
season pass okay so this is the lone
wolves season pass
all right new death animation
some
fun little
here
anything good i'm not going to poke
through every single thing here i'm just
going to kind of
oh
hey
hi charity oh i like that color
i also quite like that that's pretty
good
let's see
so many skins
okay it's pretty on point with what they
had before which is
what 343's always kind of said is that
at least this season isn't going to be
too different from
how the
past season was
which i know a lot of people aren't
thrilled about uh including myself if
i'm being honest i
was kind of hoping
for the game to feel a little different
in terms of uh its progression but i
know that that's a slow process um sorry
did i say bungie i'm in 343. apologies
if i said bungie um
anyway apparently i can get the that ai
that's cool
uh
before that oh
let me see this helmet
yep that's rad i would like that
okay that i actually want that looks
sick
that is legitimately really cool
okay
when we get near the end here
oh cool we get uh that one guy who's on
the table
get his whole outfit
a little bit of effect
oh
that's neat
i'm into that that's pretty cool
all right so that's about what we get
from the full season pass we also have
interference which is the
little mini event
looks like it gets us uh
some more stuff as well i don't know why
it's loading cinematic i don't want the
cinematic get out of here
did it start up the cinematic again
oh a different cinematic
we came up together
he's a fighter
but that banished ai it's gonna kill him
if we don't act fast and break a few
rules i gave the order to upload the
schematics of the banished facility on
canberra to our combat simulation
and now
there's an open door for erratus
i need you and as many spartans as
possible to hit the sim and when you do
i'm betting your artist gets well
irritated angry enough to leave thin and
go after you and when he does
we'll slam the door shut behind him
so yeah you and your teammates are the
bait
try not to get bitten
interesting okay
all right
enough of this let's get into the game
i think we've seen enough
menus and cut scenes and loading times
i'm just ready to play here
i'm not even gonna worry about how my
character looks
uh
okay let's see here so we got last
spartan standing
that's that new mode i also
would like to
ideally check out the new maps it
doesn't seem like they have a
king of the hill i'm gonna start with
king of the hill because
i have not played this game
in
a while
so
i need to get my sea legs back here and
something something like lone wolves
maybe is a little much to start with
xcom vibes here a little bit yeah some
of that cutscene stuff kind of like xcom
vibes
all righty
king of the hill
i'll be honest king hill is never my
favorite mode in halo but
uh i'm curious to see how i feel about
in this one
i also didn't love oddball it was always
one of my least favorite modes um i
actually liked it oddball more in this
game so maybe
maybe it's better than this one
feels okay all right let's go
always weird when you're
playing at a different set up than you
used to especially a mouse keyboard
oh no my grenade bindings not right
that's gonna be a problem
hold on we gotta fix that real quick
your team about to score
um
i just forgot what it was
uh
um
enemy team took the hill
i like this map so far
overshield available
i'm always a fan of when they're they do
the forerunner stuff but it's like mixed
in with oh this is a [ __ ] bear
when it's mixed in with sort of like
uh ruin and grass
um one of my favorite maps in halo 3 uh
guardian i think it's called um
is like this
enemy
inbound
solid there
kill control
okay
slowly getting my
let's see like spectre over here
please collect your power items enemy
team took the hill
i need to find some guns on this map
i don't know where anything is
oh okay sorry i got me
you're definitely more coordinated than
us enemy team nearing victory
nice good job guys last possible second
okay
yeah king hill's okay i don't know
it's just never been my cup of tea
but i'm glad they put in this game
because it was definitely weird that it
was not in that launch because i don't
know king of hills like a halo staple
doing my part okay
well why don't we switch over to last
bar and standing i'm sure i'll do
terrible but i want to see what this is
all about
so i think the big thing
with the second season because i
was re when this came out last year
super into it played a ton
i want to say i put like a good 80 hours
into it or something like that
and did all the battle pass
and once i did the battle pass i was
like okay i've kind of had my fill for a
bit
and i'm gonna take a break until the
second season starts which i imagine is
what a lot of people did
but having kind of looked at the second
season so far
it's like okay it's uh
kind of more the same kind of the same
grind
a lot of problems people had
and so
it's also just as long like it goes all
the way till november which is
in my opinion way too long for a season
a season of a multiplayer game to last
you need you need to be shorter and i
know they're doing that because just
sort of like the way they're currently
releasing stuff and i know there's a lot
of behind the scenes things about the
way 343's kind of like back end works
that makes it really hard for them to
add new stuff at a faster pace
and i know they're trying to fix that
and i definitely sympathize with that
but from a player's standpoint
i look at this and i go
okay
i'm not gonna play this for six months
the same event i'm gonna either
finish the battle pass and then stop
again
or
am i even going to finish the battle
pass this time because
i played so much of it then because it
was new
and i was having a really good time with
it
but you know that feeling's kind of worn
off now
so am i going to stick with this in the
long terms i'm not
i'm not sure
i don't know yet because
uh i still like
this game a lot like the fundamentals
are really strong and it's also
providing a type of multiplayer
experience that you don't
get
um from other games right now uh you
know
like halo is very unique it stands apart
from all the other
sort of like multiplayer shooters and
free to play stuff
it's different from cod it's different
from battlefield it's different from
obviously like [ __ ] like fortnite um the
only real game that i would say comes
close to matching halos vibe is
split gate which is that really
excellent free to play
multiplayer game where it's halo meets
portals it's very good
but uh i'll admit that like halo just
like has that
that special sauce that uh
other games don't
and so i want to keep playing more
but
i don't know is it enough
because because like oh and like last
time i played halo
religiously was uh halo 3
i play that like every day i really care
about you know that game didn't have a
battle pass or anything so it's like
well
why would i
i just played it because i liked it but
it they did also regularly put out maps
and updates
okay level one
zero out of a hundred i have no idea how
this mode works let's find out together
they said it's a twist on gun games i
assume
it's kind of the same thing
charge successful okay i can level up
nice okay
also
love the look of this map
how cool okay no radar also
ah this is a terrible place to be
anyone over here
no
let's see if we can get to this guy
oh shoot
all right
okay
this is uh it's a little intense with
the map size i'll say that
okay so i don't go down
or anything
oh i do keep my other gun okay
no
ah
are the latency issues fixed uh
i'm not you have to remind me what those
were i never had any latency issues uh
granted i was always i've always been
playing on pc i've never played on
console so i don't know if that was a
console specific thing or if that was a
game-wide but
i personally never had any
real concerns with latency
oh please yes
there we go
level up please yes
sick
[Music]
uh oh collect xp
interesting
i can level up again
hey
okay so you lose whatever gun so you
want to be careful about which gun
you're holding
when you
level
[Music]
don't leave game if you're out of lives
it doesn't save challenge progression
good to know thank
you okay that's a cool mechanic
that that whole risk reward thing there
oh hold on
is this the new big team battle map
yes i believe this is the new big team
battle map
and yeah it's interesting seeing a mode
like this on it i mean that makes sense
it kind of adds to that whole
stalking around really trying to find
people
it
it works so far
[Music]
yeah like that
okay
come on okay so you can see the bonus xp
on the map
uh
okay okay i'll take it
i wonder what the score is uh
not sure i guess i'm somewhere in the
middle
shotgun okay
danger zone incoming what
what does that mean
oh that's probably the danger zone okay
so
don't go that way
i just need to find people
okay three more
take it
[Music]
i should probably ride the wave of this
right
three spartans remaining
okay dangerous nun comes from that side
too got it it's a circle
makes sense
oh all right
uh
[Music]
no that's gonna work
no
oh i was eliminated
i may quit the match without panic
continue expect a challenge progress
will not be lost interesting
but then the person in the chat was just
telling me that apparently you don't
gain any progress so you do want to
watch
although it seems
they should fix that that doesn't seem
right
let's see
it's these two guys
who's gonna win
see i guess this is sort of their their
battle
royale mode
it's interesting
i kind of dig it
based on just this one very brief match
third i'll take third
that's not bad
okay
give them points
very nice
okay
anything with this nope cool
uh
yeah let's do that one again
that was interesting
i wonder if i can um
right because you can always go back to
the
previous battle pass if you want how
many boosts anyway
60 minutes
let's get the run back
should probably change my skin
i'm sure it's not helping although i
don't think you can do it when
you're
loading in
okay i can't equip while loading
rip
dennis i agree i also miss firefight
firefight's cool i need to check out the
flood fight they added into
um
master chief collection for odst that's
really cool
for those who don't know it's basically
like they took a fan mod
where it's firefight but with the flood
and then they made it like an official
thing in that game
seems sick
and i should play that only single
combatants need apply okay
oh all right
playing badly
oh this way i'm gonna get eliminated
real quick
so i don't know how they determine that
oh
[Music]
[Music]
okay
voodoo
oh get out of here with that nonsense
hmm
dynamo
acquired
oh
with the stuck
damn all right that was a lame match all
right uh
i'm gonna test leaving seeing if i do
actually keep my score i'm not gonna sit
there
and just watch these guys on a stream
let's find out
yeah you don't get any wow
hmm
i don't like that that's bad and they
should fix that
that's really bad
you i appreciate that you don't get
penalized but
hey
you are
you should get your your points
man
that's uh
that's disappointing let's um
why don't we switch back over to king of
the hill
and try some more of this
man oh
three four three come on guys
someone should let them know on the
forums yeah hopefully they do
um
hopefully that's something they can
easily fix
i it's entirely possible
that i mean look
people at 343 are smart they're not
stupid i'm sure they are
perfectly aware that it does that and
it's i bet you it's some weird like
oh the way it's set up if you quit the
game it just
automatically doesn't trigger the points
and it only triggers it if you leave the
match and i'm
they probably built it that way and then
when they added this mode they were like
shoot
so
still though
you kind of need to fix that
otherwise
this mode just like why would you play
it from from like if you're just like oh
well i'm never gonna win
and i'm never going to gain points then
because i don't want to sit there
i just wouldn't play it i would just
play other modes
okay
hill ready
enemy team took the hill
enemy team took the hill
i see you all debating about how i'm bad
at video games love it love that
uh
yeah man i haven't played halo in a hot
minute so i consider myself like above
average in halo i'm not like the best in
the world but pretty pretty good it's my
shooter of choice but and play this in a
hot minute so like
uh
i don't expect myself to to be amazing
and apologies for that if i'm not living
up to your standards uh but you know
that's just how i'll be
hopefully yourself a fun time watching
at least
to clarify um
saying uh i'm bad at video games and
when you're bad you get fired uh my job
here at gamespot isn't to be good at
video games my job is to be a video
editor who plays games and captures them
as well as does video projects behind
the scenes
uh studio live streams so
uh yeah my job description isn't
actually uh be good at video games
it's just enjoy video games
and uh you know
make good content around video games
enacted
skewer available
victory hey everyone
[Music]
look at that
[Music]
it's all good dude uh yeah man just
be uh be polite to people on the
internet you know
all right i'll just keep uh
keeping the hill going for one more
and then i i will switch back to lone
lone wolves because i do i want to keep
trying that
so i'm curious everyone in the chat here
who's all watching um
i would love to hear from all of you how
you're
feeling about this so far
do you feel like they're they've added
enough stuff for you to like come back
or at least for like a little bit i mean
it's free so like that's nice but
kind of what i was talking about earlier
i am very curious how much uh
people are gonna come back and how much
they're gonna stay right because
i
i'm very wary of whether this will be
enough to last till
november and i know they're adding some
new stuff um
they said they're gonna add forge
uh in beta i believe in like september
and i think they're trying to add
co-op in like late august hopefully
okay so bob jones you said you didn't
play any halo season one so i'll be all
new to you okay well that's good then so
if yeah you mean you got a full uh
uh
yeah you got like a whole breadth of
content to enjoy and have fun with um
and you can go back and play that old
season pass which is kind of cool
brick says they never left
good man
see that's the thing like
at the end of the day like for me like
it's it's the
it's this weird this is weird thing
where
you know
in theory you shouldn't care about
like a battle pass or like as long as
you're just enjoying the game and having
a good time with it like
you play that for as how long for long
you want right
um but i think our we're just so trained
nowadays to be expecting new stuff
that when it doesn't do it it feels like
oh this game is just
dying or
you know hemorrhaging players and
it's weird because it's like
part of me feels that way about this
game because i'm like oh they're not
putting out new enough new stuff at it
at a faster rate but also i go i don't
know like the core games still really
fun and
that never stopped me before when i was
playing
halo 3 and two for a few hours as a kid
but
enemy about to score
bob jones says the dead game talk will
happen all the time dude that is so true
it's hilarious seeing people you'll have
a game that's like
still really popular and then the second
like
one big twitch streamer is like oh i'm
kind of done playing this everyone will
be like oh it's a dead game now
dead game
you're like really guys like okay
i think the phrase dead game
i find to be
uh
rather obnoxious because like
okay sure who cares
are there still enough people playing it
to have fun
come on guys not every game is uh
oh god what is that um
that game that came out
that uh
blizzinski's studio worked on that like
died immediately i actually liked it um
but like no one played it
lawbreakers that's the game
if you're doing better than lawbreakers
you're fine
lawbreakers was the only example where
the phrase dead game really did apply to
it within
like
two days of its launch
oh and i felt bad because i actually i
actually liked that game
i think they made a mistake
making that cost money instead of being
free to play that was that was kind of
what killed it
apart from just like uh the
it was trying to capture that sort of
like mid-2000s
edgy
uh aesthetic which uh i mean i grew up
on so i have a certain fondness for but
like i get that that's that's not gonna
be most people's
cup of tea
anthem anthem is another one that was
he could maybe argue his dead game
pretty quick as well oh anthem
main city
nice
[Music]
your team about to score
let's score
no
spanker available
hill control
paddleborn battleborn was also yeah
oh battleborn
man
that was a that was a weird one
i love the chat just coming up with all
these like games that just died on
arrival brink evolved
anarchy reigns
bleeding edge ben talking about bleeding
edge in the chat heck yeah ben
leading edge was i liked bleeding edge
but i could tell immediately that first
week that like oh this game's not gonna
last
more than like a month or two
and it didn't
division two division two is a weird one
because they they keep updating that
game and i assume it's got a player base
um
but
it definitely like
people stopped talking about it
uh
it did not like stay in like the public
conscious the way division one did
that's just like a weird ubisoft thing
where
there are so many ubisoft games that you
just don't hear people talk about
anymore but they keep updating it
because there is just apparently a
player base for it like uh for honor
great example i like that game the game
is actually pretty cool but you don't
hear anyone talk about that game anymore
right it's not like oh that's one of the
we think like the big
multiplayer games that people play like
the siege obviously but no one thinks
about
uh
for honor and yet they keep updating for
honor and putting out new stuff which to
me says
people are playing that game which is
good for them i'm glad because that game
is also an example of like a unique
melee focused multiplayer game and there
needs to be more of that because
uh there's just there's so much
potential there
but i get that it's really hard to do
right
and get people to
into it
okay we're almost we're at one o'clock
so we're kinda we're kind of nearing the
end i'm sorry that i
didn't actually get to play more
because
of just the delay with the uh
the update happening on steam i should
have anticipated that and also brought
an xbox in so
a little late on my face there i'll
definitely do that next time but we're
gonna close out here with another last
spartan standing i wanna see if i can do
a little bit better
remember mag
i never got to play mag i always thought
that was cool but i didn't i didn't own
a
a ps3 at the time so i didn't play it um
or maybe i did own a ps3 at the time i
don't know why i didn't play it then but
no i never
i never played it
it seemed like a cool idea
smoke a bowl and play some more games
uh not on work hours
i don't think i'm allowed to do that
maybe maybe if i ever start streaming on
my own again
i'll do that
fallout 76 updating as well but not my
cup of tea yeah i tried to get into that
one a couple times and
i just got bored of it after a while
elimination
thanks bob jones appreciate it yeah just
don't just don't tell tay don't tell my
boss
and i'll be fine it'll be fine right i'm
saying this out loud no no one actually
watches these streams right i can say
that i'm good all right
okay
i wonder is this the only map
that this is on that's interesting i
would assume they would do it on other
maps this map makes sense though because
of uh
it doesn't have like large open fields
the way some of the other big team
battle maps do so this
works better but
i'm curious if this is the only map for
this
come on where are y'all
and get in there
no
where'd they go
oh
oh
wall
okay
what the heck happened there was that
just that bad of a shot
i think he had no shield okay that's
embarrassing
either that or
the hit detection is just not on point
but
i'll uh i'll take the point for that one
okay
ah
dang also they i'm realizing
did they nerf the
the uh what's it called the mauler
mangler do they nerf the mangler it
doesn't do the whole
one-shot uh melee thing anymore
which might explain why i'm i'm doing
bad with it because i'm not used to the
i'm expecting it to
get them
um let's see richard uh says i have
clips of me hitting people doing no
damage so there's a problem somewhere
okay
yeah maybe something got weird with it
because that just didn't feel right
[Music]
big old patch notes i briefly looked at
the patch notes i didn't i didn't go in
depth with them i i but i knew that they
i mostly looked at like oh the map
changes in the modes um i didn't pay
much attention to weapon
weapon balances
oh
[Music]
armory stock increase
oh no
ah bummer because i had such a
had a bad opening but i was just
starting to get my groove
ah man
all right well
it's these
three guys so why don't we watch them
because i do want to get my points
we put money on here let's see
not this guy
i'm gonna put my money on the cat guy
satan's fallen son
i do like this guy's mohawk though i
assume he got that at the store
oh you know what i didn't actually look
at what they're what they're selling at
the store yet
three spartans remaining
okay
all right mohawk i got got taken down
mohawk was from an event a few months
ago oh i missed it
hopefully it comes back
i got the cat ears so as far as i'm
concerned i'm happy like i don't i don't
need anything else
that mohawk is kind of cool though
here we got iron man and then we got uh
other guy
ghost rider we'll call him ghost rider
um
well they're kind of near each other i
think
oh they're all so far away
see this is what i'm talking about this
isn't fun right like it's it's okay
right i'm here with you guys and we're
watching them and we're gonna take bats
and that'll be a fun time but if i'm
just playing this on my own
like i don't want to watch this i just
want to go to the next match
but i don't get my xp
right like there's
because it's just that's what i did
before i just left and i got nothing
all right let's see it
oh cat guy come on
i believe in you
oh cat guy no
don't get killed by the circle
nice look at that look at that recovery
come on cat guy
danger zone incoming
oh man if only he had like a good
long-ranged
that have been that have been perfect
let's get this kind of here and this
guy's up there
yes yes get him get his ass
his ass no
cat guy
is he out
oh no cat guy might have gotten ah
i think we lost cat guy
right caddy me cat face or my cat face
all right then well
the horse i was backings out so
i guess uh
it's between
uh iron man
and uh ghost rider here
iron man took it
and i got fifth
well played
oh thank you richard uh yeah this is
gonna be my last game here so i'm gonna
hop off in a sec uh
so i do yeah okay you do earn points for
waiting so
you have to wait
wow that sucks
they should fix that
but yeah that's about gonna do it for me
um i guess i could just let me quickly
just look at the shop if there's
anything
cool
[Music]
not really
it's just more stuff i don't know
whatever
anyways thank you guys so much for
sticking with us uh through
those of you who stuck around from the
beginning of the stream where we were
just waiting for like 40 minutes really
appreciate that
and then uh yeah um
this is halo infinite um season two day
one seems alright
i
like lone wolves
if they could just fix that whole
xp thing that would make it a lot better
as of now
that's
gonna really prevent me from want to
play more of it so i don't know about
that but yeah otherwise uh i don't know
more halo i'll probably play a little
bit more for sure i mean i still like
halo and
yeah hopefully you guys have a good uh
rest of your day and i will catch you
all uh next time alright peace
you